[Music]
Both of you
trying to get
you can do one hand or the other. I
don't know. I wouldn't do the zombie
thing if I were you guys. Okay.
>> But Both of you are like blocking lots
of places.
>> So you block. What are you going to do?
You block and then you're looking for
this like a ledge like that.
>> You see? But if you look at her spine,
it's not all that compromised. And don't
don't move anything. Okay? For example,
this tilt. If you straighten your head
better, no, like here. See, you're like
that. I have no control over her head
from this angle. You move your head up
and down all around. I cannot stop that
from happening. So you going here for
for no freaking reason. And that's
making your center of gravity go up.
>> But you don't have to. Now stay stay
where you are and from here straighten
your spine. Do you see?
>> I'm not telling you to go back. I'm just
You're hunched.
>> Do you get it? And I can't make you I
want you to hunch and unhunch. You see
that? I I cannot control that from here.
>> I can't control her head. You get it?
So, I get that there's some tilt here,
but if you would fix your head and fix
your spine, I'm not telling you to go
back. You're doing just you're punching
for no reason.
>> Okay?
>> So, she's pretty freaking balanced. So,
stay just stay where you are. You don't
need that hand. Just stay where you are.
Okay, I'm going to take my hand away.
Stay where you are.
>> Where was her line of gravity? It's
inside her base of support.
>> There's this is not kazushi. Okay. So,
what happens is you guys will get here
in the other hand. Okay. You'll get here
and now you just kind of push this into
some semblance of the front inward
kazushi.
>> Okay. So I'll I'll say it again is
you'll find some ledge. There it is. And
then you push you're pushing it. Okay.
And there was of course those who go
that way. But even here you guys are
like pushing it into that. Okay.
We go. And I want to use the the the
yield on the adhesion. Do you see that
difference? Okay. Stay where you are.
Okay, got it.
>> You see?
>> So, again, this is very common cuz we're
in a contestation is you're like, I I
can feel that. And then you try to use
that, but it's actually over here. And
then you'll find
find that. Okay,
>> you guys understand? So, you have to
look at all the places where you're like
stopping her
>> and then realize you're trying to stop
just so you can find a ledge to now do
that kind of stuff. Okay?
>> It's not the same. So, we're here. You
see, it's on that hand. Again,
if I just get out of the way, it doesn't
do anything cuz she's trying to counter.
So, she wouldn't fall off balance
like modern Iikido imagines
people will do. Do you know, you move
out of the way and they're they're going
to fall into you and and go, "The
chair got pulled out." You know what I
mean? This this just doesn't happen. So,
you have to be the one to find the
adhesions to create the balance
breaking.
And you'll never do it by looking for a
ledge that you can now push them on.
>> It's It is on a yield. True. It's on a
yield. It's on a yield, but it has to be
sticky in order to to move them.
against it. Now again, when when when
I'm here and you feel that value,
>> okay,
you want to think she's just going to
pull back. Like you want to think that
she'll pull back, but what's happening?
It's getting stickier. Do you see that?
So again,
you in Patreon just you can't feel that.
So you don't know what it is. But I
think physics physic wise, you can
understand it. If if there is if the
fact that I'm matching
friction, when she gives me the counter
opposing force, it's going to increase
the force at the contact. And so I just
maintain that friction and it just gets
stickier when she does that
does that. Which is why when you watch
more of our advanced videos, you'll
never see Ronin pull back on that. He
has to get off of it. Okay? He can't
pull back. He has to I'll do it. Okay?
So you're you're like take it however
you want. Okay. Try to even hook it. You
could just grab it. Okay.
>> If I pull back, I'm increasing the force
there. Okay.
>> And so I don't pull back. I find a way
to go around the force. I got to free my
center from your adhesion point.
>> Okay. Um
so there is a yield. Yes. But it is an
adhesion that's pulling you into the
yield
which you either instinctually untrained
people will pull against it. It's you're
making it worse. Trained people will now
have to yin yield. Got it.
So I'll I'll just get you here. Okay.
There it is. Now you got to free the
adhesion point.
Yeah. Come on. There she goes. Okay. I
don't know why you would touch me again.
Okay. You free. Free. Yes. Do you see?
But pay attention. Do that same one.
Where's her hand going? Back. Back
towards her. Do you see?
>> So, she's not going to go forward cuz
that would just continue her her
kazushi. She can't pull back on it. She
has to come back into herself. And
that's the hyper yin yield that that you
want. Okay. So, when when I go here, she
hyper yin yield. Boom. This is where you
follow it in
to whatever. Okay. In our game when when
I'm here and she hyper yin heels, I
practice the following skill back to
another adhesion point.
Okay. Does that make sense?
>> All right. Try it. You You two have to
stop
stopping them. Start yielding and don't
use the projection point to do what you
should have done with the adhesion
point. Okay.
Hello.
[Music]
Um
well again repeating there is a yin
yield
but it must be
an adhesion. So let's let's put it a
little differently. Those are not either
or. There's a hidden heel
with an adhesion. Okay. So as we're
going that assaulted energy,
I have to get out of the way. You
understand? So let's let's look at that
same one.
I have the angle of deflection.
So he's pushing here, right? Stay there.
Stay there. And I'm at the distal end of
the lever.
So as as he has an intention here, he
can't do anything here. Do you
understand? You can't do anything at on
these 90°
because of the distal end lever here
theory. Got that? Okay. So, I have a
deflection. I'm I'm not going to do it
here because my lever is shorter.
So, I do it here. Okay. Yes. Then there
was the angle of deviation here. So he's
trying to hit here and I go whoa like
that. You see that? Okay. Those all of
that happened.
But if I just move out of the way, then
you have that same thing. Stay where you
are. Don't move. I'm going to let go.
And he's in perfect balance. Okay.
So I do have to do this, but I have to
get that adhesion.
That is what I have to get. So that I
create the dilemma. He's either going to
keep going or he has to get off of it.
And then we have
the other
The other thing, do you get it?
>> Yes, sir.
>> Right now, you guys have no
ide
without
getting stuff off the line.
Do you understand that?
>> Yes.
>> So, as he's going, you have to get him
off the off
the line. See, he's not on the line. And
you could you saw his balance kind of
wobble. Okay. And I'm not going to
take the throw where his balance is. So,
for example, I'm not going to try to
take his line of gravity and try to get
past that outside base of support. I'm
not going to do that. And it's not going
to be here either. It's somewhere around
here. That's too far.
That's closer. So, that's where I go.
Do you see that? Do you guys understand
that? Okay.
But he's probably going to do something.
No, he does something.
Do you do you see you get it? But if you
don't get him on his initial assault to
get him in a compromised position when
he does something, you won't be able to
as easily keep the advantage. When
you're here like that, he's going to do
something. He's perfectly balanced.
You're going to if you get it one time,
two times, you're not going to get it
the fifth part. It's not and that's
what's happening. Okay?
>> So, you have to like I always say, you
have to get him whoa
somewhere where you get his balance. And
what I am setting up in the game is his
initial assaultive energy is what I use
to
get his balance. Do you do you
understand that? Because that's what you
do in the application phase. It's not
that someone's going to touch my chest,
but there's going to be the spinal
displacement. And that is what I use
with my yin yield, but it's in an
adhesion. Okay. All right. Try it again.
>> You got to yield. You got to use his
assault.
Oh, you pushed him back into balance.
You got to use his assault. You're not
even letting him attack.
Now, Andrew, you can watch Chris's spine
how how upright it remains because she's
stopping him. Okay.
She pushes him back always. Keep it
going. Keep it going. Make him get out
of it.
Don't Don't take your knife out of the
fight, man.
Let him attack.
And And you keep taking a hand off for
no freaking reason. I don't know why.
Let him attack
a little better.
Let him attack.
Stay connected to whatever you can.
Yeah. See how you pull your hand out for
no reason
>> going and you like stop everything.
Okay. You're going to hit hit
That's what I want to use.
Okay. So, you'll see what we did here.
You're going there. Do you see this
hand? Okay. As you start to go, this
hand, this adhesions goes with that. You
see that? This hand's doing the parry.
This head is doing the balance
and I will Andrew back to Andrew. I will
take it as far as I can. She has to get
out of it and that's when you have other
things. She has to get out of it.
Attacks again. There it is again.
Eyes her attack.
Don't stop the attack. She attacks
yield. I'm pulling. She has to get out
of it. You pull back into it and you
increased it. You're not out of it. Come
on. Get out of it.
You got to spray this head. There you
go.
Okay. So, let me talk you through do
that. So, again, and this this is what
you would want in a in a fight. So, you
you're way off balance, right? I'll hold
you there. Okay? and you're trying to
like
hit with this hand. So you have like a
fist, you see, but you're teetering. You
understand? You're like you're you're
you're trying to do that. So when when
your punch comes to the face,
you're adding the energy that's keeping
you going that way. You understand?
>> So you have to free the hand. Yes.
Do you get that? What you were doing was
holding on this hand, which is going to
increase the adhesion because you're
like, I almost got it, but you but you
don't.
>> All this stems from
let them attack you.
Okay, they you let them attack you.
Don't stop them. They come in. That's
what I want. I pulled you to there. You
decide what you're going to do
and I follow.
You go again.
all comes from levy memor. Okay.
If I if I if I go here, you'll see like
it's about to lose. Do you get it? Okay.
Um but I can make
by what I do with this hand. So for
example,
this this is now going to be over yong.
Do do you feel that? Okay. But if this
hand now keeps you going that way. Do
you understand?
>> Now now it won't be over yong.
>> Okay. Right.
But sometimes
as we're going right, I'm trying to get
that it's starting to starting to
weaken. You see they start to slip
because
of it it's entering its yin phase. Well,
if what I want to accomplish requires
less adhesion, the yin phase will work.
So if I'm moving you that way, it's with
the other hand, it's doing that job.
So that is one way
that I only got let's say the adhesion
has a young value of five but the but
your balance requires a young value of
six. Do you see that? By moving you with
the other hand your balance now requires
a young value of three and five was
plenty. You see? So I'm using one hand
in this case to make whatever value is
there still viable. Okay. But sometimes
as as we're going right I can uh in this
case what I'm going to do is the two
adhesions.
Let's say they're both at three. You see
that one at three won't work. You have a
a a disturbance value of six. But
together the two will work.
3 + 3. Do you understand that? So that's
another way. Okay. And and another way
that I can do this, it's it's going to
be not so possible at the at the four
and eight. Okay. But as I get the
adhesion, like it's right here. Okay.
But you can feel it's at its edge. Do
you see that? Okay. So, I'll turn your
body to keep it
to do that. So, in this case, the it's
only at its edge. See there? It's only
at its edge when it go when it's going
straight. But once it starts to go
around me,
>> do you see?
>> It's now going to be You might want to
go on that side.
this this parallel angle
right is not going to have as much yong
value as if you was curved and I'm doing
that. You see that? So I use this hand
to turn you and then I get more
adhesion.
on that on that. You see that? So in
this case, I'm using the one hand to
increase the yong value to to do it.
Okay? So so far what I showed you is
I can move you so that the whatever yong
value I got here that was not going to
be ample is ample. Then I showed you how
to add the two together so that it is
now ample. And then I showed you how to
feed so that you get more yon value out
of that. Okay? And the takeaway is that
your hams work in conjunction with each
other. Okay? Now
when you felt those good throws, right?
You felt those good throws.
It's because you had the two hands at
the plus three plus three.
>> Do you get it? And it's kind of like
you're it you're worked out, but he's
going to do all kinds of things. And so
you need those other ways of having the
two hands feed each other. Okay, that's
what I meant.
Does that
those two ladder the first one like I'll
decrease how much is needed and now I'll
feed how much I have. Those are more
difficult. And that's why I want you to
start with. But so where we always
starting here and moving the whole
center of the icy ton. Just keep chasing
that.